actually just right after stopping that
video i realized a very simple way of
showing you that rp is congruent to ta a
little bit more of a rigorous definition
if we can show
that this triangle
if this triangle
right there
that one i drew in purple and this
triangle i drew right here are congruent
this triangle right there congruent
then i think we can make a fairly
reasonable argument that rp is going to
be congruent to ta because they're
essentially the corresponding sides of
the the two congruent triangles these
conju triangles would be kind of
flipping each other right so how can we
make that argument
well on the purple triangle this angle
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to this angle
on the yellow triangle
actually we got that from the fact that
this is an isosceles trapezoid so the
base angles are going to be the same
they told us it's an isosceles tri
trapezoid so we know that this side
right there
is going to be congruent to this side
right
and then finally they both share this
side right here they both share this
side
so we could use the argument once again
side angle side that the side and angle
and side are congruent to this side
angle inside so you could you know if
we're doing it in we could say by
sas
triangle trp
triangle trp
is congruent
to triangle
what t a p
t a p and if they're congruent then all
of the corresponding sides are equal so
then t a
is
congruent to r p
once again you didn't have to do all of
that it's a multiple choice test but i
wanted to give you i felt bad that i
wasn't giving you more rigorous
definition but anyway
more rigorous proof
so anyway problem number eleven
okay
problem number 11.
a conditional statement is shown below
if a quadrilateral has perpendicular
diagonals then it is a rhombus fair
enough
which of the following is a counter
example to the statement above
so they're saying if it's if it's
perpendicular diagonals and it's a
rhombus so if we could find something
that has perpendicular diagonals that is
not a rhombus then we have a counter
example right then this would not be
true
so let's find something with
perpendicular
diagonals that is not a rhombus
well this one has perpendicular
diagonals right the diagonals are
perpendicular to each other all 90
degree angles and this is clearly not a
rhombus is like a kite and i mean you
know this is not parallel to this and
that is not probably so this is not a
rhombus so this is definitely a
counterexample
this one does have perpendicular
diagonals but it's also a rhombus so
it's not a counter example it's just an
example of what they're trying to say
this has perpendicular diagonals it's a
square but a square is is a subset of
rhombuses so this is this is this is
another example and of course this one
does not have perpendicular diagonals
right this is not a right angle
anyway so a is the counter example
next question
problem 12.
problem 12.
which triangles must be similar which
triangles must be similar two obtuse
triangles oh that's i mean obtuse just
means that they have you know two angles
both of them have angles that are you
know one obtuse and might look like that
where
that is greater than 90 degrees there
and the other objects might be super
obtuse it might be like that it might be
super obtuse like that and clearly these
aren't similar but this angle is
obviously larger than that one
okay so this is not similar similar
means all the angles are the same so
it's slight congruent but you can scale
them in size that's how i think of them
right like this
triangle
let me you know it could be congruent to
i'm trying to draw it so it looks
exactly the same
that triangle well no but you can
imagine that imagine if i cut it cut and
pasted that right
but it would only be similar to this
triangle if i drew everything to scale
because the sides are different sizes
but all the angles are the same
that's what similar means
so let's see two scalene triangles with
congruent bases
with congruent bases well no that's not
true because i could have
that's not similar because let's say
this is their their basic let's say they
share the same base
right one scaling triangle might look
like this
might come out a little bit and then go
down like that
right and then the other scaling
triangle it has the same base right
there it might be something a little the
sides might be a little bit closer to
each other right so clearly these two
things aren't similar this angle is
different than that angle all the angles
are different so they're not similar
triangles
so that's not right
two right triangles
do those have to be similar well no you
could have a right triangle that looks
like this
where
maybe the two sides are equal
right which would that's a 45 45 90
triangle or you could have something
like this
where you have a
30
60
90 triangle these clearly are not
similar all the angles are not the same
they just they both have a 90 degree
angle
so
i'm already guessing that d is our right
answer but let's see how it works out
two isosceles triangles
with congruent vertex angles
two isosceles triangles with congruent
vertex angles
so i'm assuming when they say congruent
vertex angles
i'm assuming they mean all of the angles
are congruent
maybe i'm mism
so two isosceles triangles
let me think about it a little bit
two eyesights oh actually i think what
they mean they mean the angle in the
middle when they say vertex angle so
well let me
if that's
one of my isosceles triangles
that's one of mine and i saw these
triangles means that
that side is equal to that side and that
angle is equal to that angle the vertex
angle i'm guessing they mean is this
angle right there so if i had another
isosceles triangle let's say maybe it
was a little bit smaller
see it looks something like that
and the vertex angles are the same
if that angle is equal to this angle
well if those angles if that angle is
equal to this angle and we know it's
isosceles
so if we know
that's equal to that then that has to be
equal to that we know that all the
angles are the same how do we know that
this angle is equal to this angle well
think about it whatever angle this is
let's call this x
right
and let's call this angle y and this
angle y
we know
that x plus 2y is equal to 180
right
or that 2y is equal to 180 minus x
or y is equal to 90 minus x over 2.
right
now if this is x
and then let's call these z and z
so we know that x plus 2 z
is equal to 180 all the angles in a
triangle have to add up to 180. subtract
x from both sides you get 2z is equal to
180 minus x divide by 2 you get z is
equal to 90 minus x over do so z and y
are going to be the same angles so all
the angles are the same so we're dealing
with similar triangles so choice
choice d was definitely correct
13
13
13.
okay
which of the following facts would be
sufficient to prove that triangles abc
so that's a b c that's the big triangle
and triangle dbe so that's the small one
are similar so we have to prove that all
of their angles are similar and i can
not even look at the choices and i can
guess where this is we want to prove
that those are similar so first of all
they share the same angle right angle
abc
this angle
is the same as angle dbe so they share
that same angle so we got one angle down
right
and now let's think about it if we knew
that this angle was equal to that angle
and that angle is equal to that angle
would be done
and the best way we could come to that
conclusion is if somehow if they told us
that this
and this are parallel i'm guessing
that's where they're going now i might
have gone on a completely wrong tangent
because if those are two parallel then
these two lines are transversals of the
parallel so
that
and that would be correspond
that line that angle and that angle
would be corresponding angle so they'd
be congruent and then that angle and
that angle would be corresponding congr
corresponding angles so they'd also be
congruent so if they told us that these
are parallel or done these are
definitely similar triangles
and sure enough choice c
they tell us that a c
and d e are parallel these are parallel
that's a transversal this is a
corresponding angle that so they're
congruent
this is a corresponding angle to this
congruent so all of the angles are
congruent so we have a similar triangle
problem
problem
14
14.
okay
parallelogram abcd is shown below fair
enough parallelogram that tells us that
the opposite sides are parallel that's
parallel to that
and then this is parallel to that
okay and all the choices got clipped at
the bottom but i'll copy them
over
maybe i'll copy them above the question
well let me see what i can do
if i wrote it if i paste it there i
think that's good enough
a little unconventional
okay
apparently shown below and they say
which pair of triangles can be
established
to be congruent to prove which pair of
triangles can be established to be
congruent to prove that
angle dab
is congruent to angle bcd so they want
us to show that dab
dab so dab is this let me do another
color dab is that angle
is congruent to bcd to bcd so they want
us to show
that those have the same angle measure
okay and what do we have to show and
they say what pair of triangles can be
established to be congruent to prove
that
okay so we have to just show two if if
these are both part of two different
congruent triangles and they're the
corresponding angles then we know that
they're congruent and we'd be done so
let's see what they say triangle adc and
bcd
a d
c
a d c
and b c
d
b c d has this angle in it right
b c d it does help us because it has
this angle but triangle a
a d c does not have this angle in it
right triangle adc has this this smaller
angle and it has this adc doesn't
involve this whole thing so that's not
going to help us
triangle aed aed once again does not
involve this larger angle does not
involve the angle dab right it only
involves a little smaller angle so
that's not going to help us
triangle d a b that looks good that has
this whole angle in it d a b
and then b c d
right if we show that this
that
that that triangle
is congruent to this triangle right here
i think we're done that would be enough
to show that this is congruent this
angle
is congruent to that angle because it'd
be the corresponding angles of congruent
of a congruent triangle so i think c is
where we're going to go let's just look
at choice d
d e c d e c once again d e c triangle
dec let me make this point clear
triangle dec does not involve
either of the angles we care about it
clearly does not involve this angle and
only involves part of this angle only
this part doesn't involve this whole
angle so that's not going to help us
either so the answer is c anyway see in
the next video